it's easy to forget that before a legion
of juicers flocked to his stream xqc was
once a professional player what but for
those who don't know how good was xqc at
OverWatch
is crazy yeah unfortunately mine's a
little bit crazier
during the five months he was part of
the inaugural season of OverWatch League
he played a lot of Winston and he was
honestly pretty good back then
particularly his alts
xqc sets it up for akm he also
represented Team Canada at the OverWatch
World Cup where they made two Podium
finishes and he bagged the World Cup MVP
in 2017. what seems clear is that xqc's
play wasn't some weird fluke he could
hang with everyone in that first season
and he was good enough after that to
help bring Canada to the finals twice so
the next time you're hanging out in the
Stream chat with other juicers remember
you are in the presence of greatness